ونحييكم مشاهدينا من جديد بعد كل ما رشح
من تصريحات ومعلومات عن وجود رغبه في
اعاده العلاقات التركيه السوريه بعد قطيعه
دامت احد عشر عاما افدى مصدر زبلوماسي بان
موسكو 9 فعلا لعقد لقاء بنت مصالحه بين
طرفين تفاديين لعمليه عسكريه تركيه واسعه
تهدد انقره بتنفيذها منذها وذكر المصدر
اننا مساعي روسيا لترتيب اللقاء تنطلق
منطلقونها من خطوره عمليه العسكريه
التركيه شمالا تشكل مصدر تهديدا خطير
للاستقرار الاقليمي وحتى الدولي واشار
المصدر لان خطوط التواصل بين دمشق وموسكو
تكسفات منذ تعيني نائب وزير الخارجيه
السوريه بشر الجعفري سفيرا شديدا لدى
روسيا كما المحل مصدر الى دوري ايران همم
دورها الخفيه الذي يدفع الاسد
مقاومه الضغط الروسي موضحا ان الاخيره لا
يمانع اللقاء في حين تخشى طهران من نجاح
هي موسكو بخلق وفاق بين الاسد واردوغان
ينعكس سلبا على مصالحها في سوريا ظهران
وفقه محللين تخشى ابرام اتفاقات او تفهمات
بين روسيا وتركيا والنظام السوري تضر
بمصالحها هناك
[موسيقى]
هناك شهاده الملف مع ضيوفنا من اسطنبول
المحلل السياسي
عبد الحميد توفيق الكاتب الصحفي اهلا بكم
سابدا من اسطنبول معك
يقول بان القرار لافيد تركيا ولا في يد
النظام السوري
قرار امكانيه لقاء بين الاسد واردوغان في
ايدي الروس
والايرانيين روسيا تدفع وتشجع ولكن ايران
تحضر من هكذا لقاء خوفا على صالحها هكذا
تحدث مصدر للعربي ما تعليقك على ذلك
تحيه طيبه مساء الخير نعم اعتقد ان هذا
الراي اييي يحمل
حقيقيه
واقعيه اولا اريد
نقطه ان اردوغان لم يظهر رغبه او دعوه لا
اللقاء مع الاسد كلما قال انه لن يمانع في
لقاء الاسد بعدما كان يرفضه منذ اكثر من
اكثر عندما تكون هناك ظروف مناسبه همم
عرضيه جيده انه لن يمان في لقاء الاسد هذا
ما في الامر اما المماطله ان النظام او او
اظهار كانه همم يرفض هذا اللقاء تم عرضه
هكذا من قبل تركيا وهو رفض هذا همم طبعا
غير صحيح همم يعني
منذ فتره طويله هناك اسرار روسي همم
الحوار التركي الروسي التركي السوري
السياسي ولابد من ان يسبق اي اللقاء
اردوغان الاسد
تحضيرات ولقاءات ومباحثات من هذا القبيل
لخلق ارضيه مناسبه حتى يخرج هذا هذه القمه
بشيء مفيد او يؤثر على الباقه ولذلك همم
هذا الامر همم كما قلت هكذا بالنسبه
لايران مع من شك ان روسيا والايران همم له
همم له ما تاثير والنفوذ كبير على النظام
في سوريا صحيح
في هذا الاطار عبد الحميد ان صدقه هذا
الكلام كلام المصدر لقناه العربيه او
العربيه نت واكده كذلك حتى سيد اقطعك همم
النظام السوري اقرب لي اي وجهه نظر لايران
الذي التي تشدد او تمنع على هكذا لقاء او
لروسيا التي تحفز مثل هكذا عوده علاقات
مساء الخير
انا اعتقد ان المساله نسبيه بحد كبير
وخصوصا عندما يتعلق الامر بالبعد السياسي
لمثل هكذا علاقه اعتقد لا شك بان هناك
تاثيرات ومؤثيرات من الجانب الروسي كونه
الحليف الاساسي والجوهري للدوله السوريه
وكذلك ايران لها حلفها الراسخ ايضا منذ
عقود من الزمن مع جانب السوري ولكن هناك
لابد من النظر الى الموضوع من زاويه مهمه
وهي ان
المشروعين الروسي والايراني اذا سمحنا
لانفسنا بالقول في سوريا هما غير متجانسين
هما متعارضين او متبينين على الاطلاق
بالتالي اعتقد ان التاثير همم الى حد انهم
سيكولاني صاحبي قرار على الدوله السوريه
او على الجانب التركي في مساله عوده
العلاقات او انعاشاتها او حتى اللقاء بين
الرئيسين اعتقد ان هذا الكلام مبالغه
واعتقد وجهه نظر الشخصيه بان هذا الكلام
يراد منه همم التشويش على مجريات ما يحدث
بين الجانبين على مستوى الاستخبارات وعلى
مستوى وعلى الدوره الروسي اساسا الذي يسعى
بشكل حديث وليس جديدا لانه يريد ان يسجل
نقطه في هذا الاطار وهو الماذون في
المساله الاوكرانيه اتوقع ايضا بان دمشق
اذا ما ارادت ان تضع اولويات لاي همم طرفا
تميل في الرؤيا او في التوجه او في الضغط
انا اعتقد ان دمشق وعرف عنها كما كان يقال
سابقا الواقعيه التي تستخدمها او التي
الباقيه التي تتبعها في ايطاليا السياسيه
وفي اداء السياسيه وخصوصا في الظروف
الصعبه التي تمر بها على المستويات
الداخليه
بانها ستستمر بالجانبين بما يتاح من هذا
وذاك لخدمه موقفها التي تسعى الى تعذيزها
في الجانبين لان سيقول بانهما خطان
متوازيان لن يلتقيا في مصلحه امكانيه لقاء
تركي همم سوري هكذا يقول البعض ووو وسيد
اقطعي همم تاخر همم رد فعل النظام السوري
مع هذه التصريحات حتى وان لم تكن هناك
دعوه صريحه من اردوغان ولكن ان يمد يده
لنظام السوري في هذه دعوه لتطبيع العلاقات
بطريقه كامله تاخر التفاعل السوري وضعه
البعض في اطار همم
امكانيه تاثير كبير لايران على نظام
السوري حضرتك كيف تقيم هذه النقطه
طبعا في في السابق قبل الروس همم في همم
الشهور الصيفيه في الصيف الماضي ايران
طاهرا اعرض مثل هذه البساطه
وبدات المباحثات التركيه السوريه ولكن لم
يتم يعني ايران اذا همم يحصل مثل هذا
اللقاء يريد ان يحصل عبر طهران عبر
الوساطه الايرانيه ليه للحفاظ على نفوذها
وتاثيرها
والتحكم في سير الاحداث هذا من جانب من
جانب الاخر انا لا ارى ان ايران بشكل
[موسيقى]
غير راغب في اي تقارب التركي السوري من
جهه او التركي الى العربي حتى انا
التقارب التركي العربي تقارب تركيا مع
الدول الخليج في الفتره الاخيره مع مصر
همم
ازعجت حقيقه همم طهران
ااا كذلك يعني حتى تحركات التركيه في
القوقاز ازعجت بشكل همم معلن جدا همم
وبادر همم
بالمبادرات مع الجانب الروسي والارني همم
لتقليص همم هذا الثور الامريكيه
بانها المقاومه
في تقارب بلدان المنطقه لان النظام
الايراني بالظبط عامل عدم الاستقرار في
المنطقه
ويتغذى من من استمرار الازمه وعدم
الاستقرار همم سيد عبد الحميد كنت حاضر
معنا في حلقه سابقه وطرحنا نفس هذا
الموضوع او زاويه من زوايا هذا الموضوع
قبل ان تصلنا هذه همم تاكيدات عن مصدر
العربيانات ولكن قلت وقتها بان الموضوع لا
يخص جهاز الدوليه بقدر ما هو همم ما يخص
مطالب سوريه من الجهه التركيه هناك ملفات
موضوع على الطاوله يجب على هذه الملفات ان
يعمل عليها بطريقه الجزئيه حتى تبدا خطوات
التقارب همم ما ابرز هذه الملفات
نعم هذا صحيح وهذا واقع ولا احد يستطيع
انكاره وهي معطيات على ارض الواقع منها
الوجود العسكري التركي حتى لا نكرر كثيرا
الذي يحتل شريطا طويلا وهو هذا جانب
والجانب الاخر سوري سوري اريد ان تطمئن
ايضا على ان لا اطماع في المستقبل لتركيا
في الاراضي السوريه وسوريه ايضا تريد ان
تنهي حاله الوجود الارهابي للمنظمات
وتحديدا منظمه الاسره في همم بعض من مدينه
او محافظه ادلب ومحيطي اللاذقيه وشمال
وشمال ايضا هذه الملفات هي الاساسيه التي
تتعلق بالرمز السيادي للدوله السوريه وما
تبقى من ملفات الاخرى واعتقد ان احد عناصر
التفجير او احد عناصر
التاجيل في اطلاق عجله العلاقه السياسيه
او التفاهمات السياسيه على خلفيه
التفاهمات الامنيه القائمه باعتراف
الطرفين اعتقد بان موضوع همم قوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه وتواجدها ومحاولات كموضعها
وتقلباتها الجانب السوري يريد ان يوصل
رساله الى الجانب التركي بان هذه المساله
يمكن بحثها ويمكن حلها ولكن بعد ان تتبلور
المواقف التركيه الجانب التركي
متعجل لكي يضع حدا لمثل هذه التهديدات
التي يقول بانها تهدد امنه القومي من
الجانب السوري وسبب وجودي هذه القوات وصل
الامر بوزير الخارجيه التركي وهذا يعني
يدل على ان جانبه التركي يريد ان يذهب
بعيدا في اي كل ال- ال- همم الهواء الجسم
الامنيه التي تحكم سلوكه السياسه وصل
بالقول جاوش خارجيه التركي في مرحله
المراه او من حوالي شهرين تقريبا قال بان
سوري تركيا مستعد ان تدعم الجيش السوري
لكي ينهي وجود الاسد في تلك المناطق التي
يهدد تركيا ماذا يعني ذلك يعني بانه هناك
حقيقه معطيات يدرك والجانب التركي هل يمكن
ان الان سال هل يمكن ان تكون هذه المصافحه
ان تحصل هذه المصافحه او ان يحصل هذا
اللقاء وهذا الواقع القائم على حاله دون
اي مقدمات انا استبعد ذلك واعتقد ان
الجانب السوري ايضا فيما لو اردنا ان نقول
بانه يتميز في هذا التوجه لا اعتقد انه
يتميز وهو يتغافل او غافر عن الامر اعتقد
بانه يحاول الاستثمار الوقت خاصه والجانب
التركي يلقي بكثير من المواقف وبشكل متدرج
همم باتجاه هي العلاقه وعوده العلاقه مع
سوريا ولكن سوريا باتتعترف
بان هذه الورقه ربما تكون جزءا من الحكايه
التركيه الداخليه ولابد من الاستثمار
رئاسيه
يعني طبعا بعض هذه المطالبه قد تكون
مقبوله ولكن معظمها
مطالب غير حقيقيه ولا واقعيه لا يمكن ان
انسحاب من هذه المناطق التي كانت تعطي
الاحتلال المنظمات الارهابيه قبل تحقيق
السن والامن في سوريا كذلك همم يعني همم
الشرط الاساسي لتركيا ل همم
للتوافق مع النظام هو موافقه النظام على
تغيير سلوكه
والموافقه على القرارات الدوليه الاماميه
التي اتخذها في اجماع الامام المتحده وهو
قرار همم 2000 همم
خمسه همم 54 على ما تذكر ينص على التغيير
السياسي والحكومه الشامله تحتضن جميع
السوريين ليست فقط فئه همم اقليه طائفيه
وما الى ذلك بدون هذا الان هذا التغيير
الجوهري حتى ان همم تقى اردوغان مع الاسد
لن يتغير شيئا يعني هناك
بانها الطريق لازال طويل لتحقيق حقيقه
لزق همم فتره
جزيلا شكرا اكيد بان هذا الموضوع سيبقى
للمتابعه من اسطنبول المحلل السياسي هو من
دمشق عبد الحميد توفيق الكاتب الصحفي شكرا
جزيلا للحضور وللمشاركه
[موسيقى]